she is my best friend and has been since
we first met in Baltimore in a newsroom
at wjz-tv she was 21 I was 22 she took a
liking to news then and fell deeply
madly in love with being informed and
with being able to inform others she
just loves it that is Oprah Winfrey
speaking about our own Gayle King last
night Gayle was honored by the
broadcasting and cable Hall of Fame we
are here for the people and that is a
truth that I believe with everything
that I know so it's times like this I
can't tell you how thrilled I am to be
up here in this room with all of you I
can't tell you what it means to me when
you can't help but remember the men and
women of the press who knew it too and
got the story told even when they
understood that it could cost them their
lives so I thank you all for thinking me
worthy not bad for a little girl whose
elementary school teacher in Ankara
informed her parents that she talked too
much and was disruptive and that maybe
they should do something about that
because I was very bright child she said
but I was a little distracting in class
thank goodness for it Gayle joins
distinguished Pass honorees including
Oprah Norman Lear Lucille Ball and
Walter Cronkite or Cronk I know I look
at the list of names too when I look at
the list I go and I'm in that class too
I'm still trying to wrap my brain around
it and it's so true when I say I really
do love what we do that we all get to
sit at this table every day it's a
privilege and it's a blessing and I
never take it for granted I did
something with dr. Phil yesterday and I
said the reason why I love it is we have
a front-row seat to history goes no you
have a press pass to life oh good I know
it's let me write that down
soundbite machine write that down I'm
not gonna credit you but I have to say
Phil said that to me yesterday I thought
that's so true we have a press pass to
life I thought the word that Diane
Sawyer used to describe you was you are
in everything and and Oprah said your
greatest gift virtue is your happiness
for other people's success kudos to you
thank you guys thank you